we're feeling very batmanny today for no
reason
i just wasn't sure what to make my
background in it so i went bat cave
i'm trying to decide who that is that's
not
oh that's a t-rex i thought it was robin
on a very bad day not just like what is
that from is that
because it feels
looks like new 52 to me does it type of
style
looks like it i don't know it's got a
bit of that but it feels i'm looking i'm
catching the fin of the batmobile right
there and
and it makes it feel a little more
should i should i just get out of the
way yeah it's just yeah you're just
looking away
see that's even a little bit movie that
batmobile that's a little bit
i wouldn't even say new 52 i would say
that's older
it could be older i'm sorry i'm geeking
out you know
are you not sourcing your backgrounds
with there's no pennies
for what it's worth there's no penny i
could check no i closed the link
um i do sort of have this like you know
i i used to read a lot of comics
and then caught myself down to only
batman because of time and money
um you know the same as like i used to
collect magic the gathering cards and
then it became a point where i was like
i should stop doing this this is not
a good idea it's not my job yeah a lot
of fun
but i have i still have like hundreds of
cards in australia and my mom's always
like can i get rid of them and i'm like
not
yet one day but today is not the day
that i'm willing to part with them
um but i did end up having this beef
around maybe like i don't know i would
say
like 2006 or so uh where
a lot of comic art started to look
exactly like what's behind me
like so much of the mainstream art
started to look exactly the same and i'm
not entirely sure why it all started to
look that way like the shading was all
exactly the same everything was very
cool and hue
and and everyone was like when was this
you sir i'm guessing when i was in the
middle of high school so that would be
2006-ish
but i wonder if that's the the upswing
of the digital coloring i wonder if it's
like
if no that would have been maybe i mean
that's that's
completely wrong but it definitely
seemed like it all happened at the same
time
that would coincide with when like boom
and image and vertigo really kind of
started to take off as well so
you didn't have the the mainstream guys
the marvel and dc dudes were kind of
over here and then there was like
you know brian vaughn that was popping
and
who was the colorist for that who did
the camera who did why the last man
uh colors yep see that's a unique art
style
like i like that odd style a lot um that
doesn't look like everything that
that no that's why i really started that
2008-2009 is when i started
moving away from god
right now oh yeah we can find out who
the colorist is
we have our auntie google on this show
definitely
don't know what i don't understand
that's what we call mic by the way
what's the problem i i never understand
your your batting average for having a
relevant book
pretty damn high despite the fact that
that
that bookcase doesn't look like it could
hold more than like a hundred books
so it's it's forty percent jars of we
still haven't determined what's
in those i think it's lego we have yeah
it's lego i know it's lego
yeah i can't see my copy of why the last
name i'm always curious about why there
are shoes on there
i also want to that i'll show you
they're lovely they were um custom
shoes made by someone for me a fan made
them and sent them to me
oh that's cool it's almost like oh my
god oh wow that's really good isn't that
nice
oh wow that's awesome yes they bought i
had someone make me custom jordans that
were hawkeye
inspired wow and they're someone told
them they're like
we got your your shoe size i was like
are you serious and someone gave them
the wrong shoe size so i've never worn
them
but they're awesome they're like what
are you like a 13
no 12 all except for
one pair my wife got me for christmas
she got me the jubilees the 25th
anniversary ones that i've always wanted
they're the ones that i would literally
want to go to all the cool kids in high
school right now and go
boom [ __ ] because i finally got them
and they'd be like why did you break
into our house so
yeah they're like do you remember who i
am no no no
no um by the way
your phone's ringing it's it's the
security company
um i i know that that person did pretty
well in life and is not relying on
police first and
you know that is true private security
yeah yeah
i had to climb a gate in that circle
there were two dobermans in that
whimsical story i made up just now
uh no but they're the only ones that are
12 and a half for legal
watching this size 12s and jordans
i'm actually going to write that down
that's useful information
[ __ ] you're getting a [ __ ] gift it's
in it if if you want to buy me jordan's
i would love that so that's what's weird
it's all my friends all my like trailers
am i like proper running trainers those
are all 12 and a half
so to be clear troy
mentions his shoe size hat size is seven
seven and eight
i bought this myself
[Laughter]
thank you for supporting this show i'm
just gonna point out
doing your biblical okay but i did buy
you guys
the merch because troy still hasn't
given me his dreams
i you didn't you're right actually i do
have the sweater
right on the other side of the piano
here
they're really nice materials uh go to
redbubble.com
people slash play watch listen i think
i don't remember we had much this is
it's been very cool to
you know because this show is largely
taken swing during the pandemic
uh people like post photos and
occasionally will tag me with it but
i've not seen anyone in person and i was
thinking about that if like the first
time that i see someone in the real
world who's wearing
play watch listen shirt or something
will probably be a very emotional moment
for me
good friend of mine who's a game
developer messaged me a photo of her
laptop today and
and you know the the back of it is
completely covered in stickers and there
was a little
play watch listen sticker recently added
to join the repertoire
among alongside like gdc stickers which
made me shed a tear but
um but what i've heard
on the inside uh gamescom is expected to
come back
in full swing this year they are
expecting gamescom to be
open open open isn't it like september
range gamescom is like
300 000. there's no way it makes it
makes san diego look like
sparse that's not happening and if it
does then that will be the cause of the
next wave of the pandemic
yeah we'll stay there forever because
the game is calm like what do they
benefit from that
is it not just like think about the
millions of dollars that are being
saved also not generated for
specifically cologne
but i bet cologne just breathed a
considerable sigh of relief the city to
be clear
yes yeah game gamescom is not a uh
colonial
with a little bit perfume cologne some
of those smells like disappointment
it was common stinkiest it is it's so
well i have a problem with gdc because
it often rains at that point of the year
in san francisco so it's really humid
indoors and gdc so it gets really sticky
is that the end of the day
it rains at that point of the day at gdc
that was sorry that time of the year but
it gets real smelly um
but i was gonna say with with gamescom
i imagine that everyone in the city of
cologne was like well it is nice to have
a break for a year because
you know we kind of go in there and
overtake everything yeah it's
not great imagine just the day after
when they just look at the the remains
of their desecrated hamlet of a village
it's not a large town
it's incredibly small and they're just
like look what they
hundreds of thousands of branded
t-shirts just
hanging from the bags just like
thrown just yeah that's just kind of
like the uh
sort of like the olympics on a you know
order of magnitude smaller scale but
i've always read that
the olympics are it's strange how cities
compete for them but it's a well-known
thing that it's very economically
damaging to the cities that host the
olympics because
they they invest i've always heard that
i can't i can't uh offer you a citation
in this moment but i've always
understood that
that um they invest billions in the
infrastructure
of hosting all these people hosting
these athletes you know all the
all the various uh equipment media all
that this is just
it's a giant circus like literally
millions of
people and thousands of athletes and all
of that and
and um it just can't possibly recoup but
specifically for london
that like overhauled london
that is when the city expanded the most
to the east like the docklands became
incredibly accessible that doesn't mean
london at the time it was
it was massive yeah my brother-in-law
works in that industry and i know
specifically for
sydney uh they used it as an excuse to
create facilities that the city really
needed
so yeah yeah it's still very frequently
used like it's used for concerts it's
used for
our video game expos um or it was i
think they shut those down but
there are also housing out there so they
used it well but i mean i think that was
the year 2000 so it's like
i would imagine those grounds yeah
that's what supernova was
yeah um i think the compound does look a
bit like a compound but that's it
could very well be it could be some
people probably do it well some don't
that may be the reason why they justify
the expense is that they will gain
something it's a loss leader on
something that will have long-term value
i think that's what it is and i mean
just the job
in the industry right it sells the town
out right so like
it's it's all the tourists that come in
but not profitably is the thing because
that's what i've always heard again i
could be completely wrong
but it does seem to make an intuitive
amount of sense just given
the insanity and they probably have all
these
deals you know that i'm sure there's a
lot of folks that are coming in with
various sweetheart deals that you know
they would lose money on just all the
various governments and
you know it's it's because it's so it's
so unique there's no event like it with
literally hundreds of of individual
governments and
visas and all that just think of the
insanity uh
it's really um i've never been i've
always thought it would be interesting
to go
to the olympics uh just be just if only
to behold in person
the madness of it you know it's
it's uh i just think of like you know
spaniard
fifty thousand romans following the
movement of your sword like it just
feels like the most same thing just how
long it's been around
and like thinking about the way that
it's evolved everyone used to be naked
i know how did the recent version start
though because it's not been going the
whole time 30s right
it was the 30s right yeah i think so i
thought it was earlier i thought it was
earlier than that
but it was the 20th i think it was
hitler that brought it back but i
it no actually you know what in the 1936
olympics
when hitler says i declare these
olympics open i think
that that might just mean posting them
and then jesse owens won the
i think that i'm going to look it up
because yeah okay this didn't feel right
1896.
okay what was the big deal
i guess that besides because they were
in they were in berlin where they were
in berlin
and that was the first brought i think i
know this because of contact i was going
to say i see this coming
um that was the first uh
television transmission no it wasn't i
think it was just
the highest powered at that highest
powered wow
that's the one that could reach out into
space and so that's what in carl sagan's
book the aliens threw back at us they
were like here you go
like oh no
yeah it's a great it's a great i love it
and the movie is so good too they like
turn it upside down
this way i love that moment though
that's a perfect moment that's actually
an amazing moment of
of when dispassionate scientific inquiry
meets ideological uh blindness where
they're the instantly all the government
people are like
oh [ __ ] aliens must be nazi
sympathizers we've lost troy
austin can i just say from his safety i
love the first part of that sentence was
so eloquent you it was beautifully
phrased and then the second one was like
and then the government people are like
oh [ __ ] aliens
hey we got some [ __ ] aliens i
i am a believer in the heterodox even
within myself
i will i will i will pivot less
wonderful right
yeah but no it's amazing i i just
recently rewatched that
that movie and i i love where they're
where they they fight it they say you
know
it's just it's just the luck of the draw
of the transmission
they don't even know what they're
sending back uh
and and and you know the all the
military people feeling very
suspicious over that conclusion having a
hard time trusting it and
i feel like and the funny thing is if
you made that movie now
the i think the the general
sort of electrified nature of everything
would generally fight nature
all of that is so much more amplified um
i'm going to intro the show right now
we're at 15 minutes oh man
i just feel like there's so much stuff
that we could be talking about this week
and
i know emma watson isn't retiring all
the news happened this week and we're
talking about but i i
will say that there was by and large i i
did the combing through the comments
the comment combs and people loved
like our we thought you were gonna talk
about this and you didn't and people
yeah i've never changed again i'm never
gonna make it more structured i think i
told someone to
watch a different show i was like
greg miller greg miller just some video
game stuff you should check
by all means please alana i i apologize
for interfering
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of play watch listen i'm a lot
of ps video game writer that's troy
baker video game actor that is austin
wintry video game composer and that's
mike biddle video game director
uh did you guys see the playstation
conference yes
i think i did i'm not prepared for this
at all it's all right it was only like
half an hour and no major news
okay i watched the truth and i didn't
watch the presentations that came out
that other than that there wasn't
there was no horizon actually really oh
okay
there was more death loop which uh oh
okay my gosh i am excited about that
game
looks great uh ah so into it and and
i have a question about that yes did it
the the i love the kind of the the bond
treatment that they gave it yeah but the
flipping back and forth between styles i
don't know if it was like here's our key
art here's our graphics
here's our key art here's our graphics
and they at some point they felt
like it was i i maybe it's my ignorance
but i felt like the message was getting
mixed in that of going
what does the i understand that this
looks like this because it's a first
person shooter i get it
but then you're also presenting this
super stylized
thing as a layer on top of it so i just
didn't understand
i think that probably happened because
they've shown this game a lot
so they had to do something different
the game's been shown at the last like
three or four conferences
um so the uh the addition of the style
is definitely for the song to make it
very bond
ish which i really liked um but the
gameplay looks like the bits that look
kind of like dissonde
it's it is arcane but i'm very excited
about it uh i think it looks so cool and
i love the idea of like
hitman meets bond sort of um
which you know they are working on uh
meets dishonored
like just so so so cool um very excited
to play it also like the news that i
think
uh ratchet is gonna be on ps plus for a
while
and i always feel like i want more
people to play ratchet and clank as a
franchise that is already extremely
popular i'm like but it's also
way better than you think it is it's
like ratchet is very i've never played
i have never played that one that's
not the first i don't think first one
and then the new one that they they
what was it um kraken time uh yeah
kraken time whatever i think
i played that when it came out for a hot
second um
very pretty 2002 was the first one yeah
it's one of those that i've always been
aware of
and somehow every time i've sort of
been busy and then it retreated over the
horizon and escaped notice once i mean
they are kids games
like that that is all games are for kids
grown-ups read books
all right george lucas
best motion business as well the best
motion blur in the business insomniac
with those games they just look that's
what gives them that kind of
pre-rendered quality is the beautiful
mocap no no sorry no mocap by motion
interesting that is a thing that i feel
like different games have been toying
with
recently more so or maybe it's just that
i started streaming more
um but i feel like i often have people
ask me to turn motion blur off
that's the thing that i feel like so
there's a couple of different versions
there's uh like motion blur as a post
effect which is
all the camera and then there's per
object motion blur which
is so so so you're going to be able to
turn that off
is that baked into this you could turn
it you could turn off either no no you
can turn off either but basically it's
to do with how you render it and which
order you render in
motion blur in kind of the way we kind
of had it in kind of
i think of like i think our orange box
probably was like most people's first
exposure to was like in portal
the original portal i remember like lots
of motion blur as you move the camera
around
that's a post effect that you can't do
to everything what's the higher object
motion
what's the purpose of it it makes more
real right it looks smoother is honestly
the trick it kind of hides the
trying to figure out if i have more
sleep when i look around i guess
so you're full 90 frames a second oh we
can go there do we want to talk about
like how your eyes lie to you
all the time have you ever looked at it
think about that recently but not in
terms of motion blur
when you look at a mirror have you done
the thing where you look in the mirror
and look at one eye and then look at the
other eye or actually just do it now
with your web camera look
oh you can't do it next time you're in
front of a mirror phone
like look at a mirror right look at one
eye
and then look at your other eye and you
won't see your eyes move
between the two eyes because when your
eyeballs move
uh your brain stops fill uh taking
they essentially like a video feed from
them otherwise you get motion sick all
the time
so i mean i can see that both of my eyes
move uh
oh here's the question but you don't you
won't see the transition between the you
won't see the eyeball actually
you will the camera because of lag oh if
you're doing
a camera you won't if you look in the
mirror you won't see
your eyes moving because your brain if
you think about like like
just in your room now look at one thing
over there and then look at another
thing over there without moving your
head just your eyes
you don't see a blur right you don't see
a motion blur because your eyes switch
off
in that gap your brain knows that when
your eyeballs are moving it shouldn't be
taking video
and you're unconscious of it you're
unaware of it but it means you're not
seeing that motion taking place
um your brain switches off in those
moments so if you look in the mirror
like get up close to a mirror
look at one of your eyeballs look at the
other eyeball you won't see your eyes
swivel you'll just
see your eyes staying still and jumping
from one view to the other
because your brain switches off you know
that do you know that because
it became necessary for you to ask that
too or or was that just like
i'm a big fat nerd i'm just a [ __ ] i
think that one actually i think i think
you're a very svelte nerd if i may say
oh that's very kind it's untrue but i
appreciate it the um
no the um i think that one the nicest
way of calling someone a liar
i um i think i think that one i got from
so there's a thing in the uk which is
the most uk thing that i think about
there's a thing called the christmas
lectures
which is like science for kids i think i
remember seeing the
kids the morning of december 25th and
every house
have begun before boxing day unboxing is
on boxing
this is of course about the species
found in the
equation this one is about motion blur
it's true that one is
um but that's but that's what's
interesting about motion blur and why it
annoys a lot of people because motion
blur
when it's full screen when it's tied to
camera you're
basically simulating how it looks when a
film moves a
film camera moves around very quickly
you your
head when you're looking around you
don't see motion blur unless you're
moving your head really fast if you move
your eyeballs you won't see it
um so it's kind of it's it's weird and
you your brain knows you're watching a
video rather than which is fine and it
kind of gives you gives everything a
smoothness
per object motion blur is cool because
that's where you literally are just
blurring
the object so the hand moving back and
forth you're blurring but you're not
blurring my face at the same time
because my face isn't moving
which is again similar to how things
look on film
but essentially just a different process
a more expensive process you have to
isolate different
parts of objects and know how fast
they're moving or to get that effect
so it's harder to do you have to blow
the hand as well right
you're blurring you're blurring the hand
basically as it moves around yeah
but you're not blurring the whole screen
so what so the cheapest way to do motion
blur
in a video game is just to basically
take the last two frames that you
rendered and then
basically render them on top of what
you're saying in this whole episode i'm
just sort of
i can see i feel like you don't have my
own hand that could be a supercar
missing out spotify
that's correct oh yeah um so that's so
when you when you say
ratchet and clank looks pixar i would
say a
large proportion of what's giving you
that vibe that you're watching a
pre-rendered film
is that per-object motion blur because
that's something that's only
only the last ratcheting cloud kind of
introduced that with games and it's it's
in lots of games now but it's a cool
thing sorry
oh teacher teacher teacher austin go
ahead miss clifton
miss clifton
[Laughter]
i
i was actually going to be on point i
was called on for [ __ ] sake
oh i thought you were just doing that
just to piss me off children calm down
austin go ahead no no troy's right he
was here first
i did have i did have a question but uh
i i will try desperately i was gonna
ping off the pixar thing so
that that could potentially move us away
from this so if you have something else
to add i would by all means not
well every word out of my mouth runs the
potential of taking this off subject so
that is a risk i'm self-aware enough
uh i was i just the way
that you phrased it mike of our eyes
lying to us um
and just the shortcuts that basically
all of our biology is taking at all
times right it's
it's kind of related to the earlier
conversations about evolution
um and it's funny how i love
conversations like
this that are unpacking all of the crazy
shortcut like the
like one i don't i think i feel like
we've mentioned it here before but this
the fact that we have essentially a
blind spot in the center of our eye
in our in our field of view that our
brain is sort of
uh constantly trying to judge it's
deleting the that's basically right
that's
yeah that's separate the uh but yes the
the idea that that
that um all of all of our hardware is
basically
designed to work just well enough
uh that's kind of that's the whole mo of
evolution
which um which is why it to me it's
always fascinating
that the notion of uh
eyewitness testimony and the fact that
we
think that that's a good thing to lean
on and hinge our
our especially criminal justice of all
things but even
even just the like i know what i saw
it's like so many
many forensic files episodes where
they've been wrong
like the person who was attacked and
stabbed is like i remember his face and
then they blamed the wrong guy
and there's so many henry ford spencer
tracy on that i just want to point out
that that's how old i
am i was like yeah that movie that that
movie that just got out of the picture
house just now
the 12 angry men the great movie if
you've never watched it it is a
fantastic play and a wonderful movie
well but
the theaters are closed so we can't go
see it troy we'll go see it on there no
other way to watch a movie
on the video store that that lives on
the computer got a blockbuster pick it
up
uh austin did you say you had a question
i had a question
[Music]
i thought that was your point i don't
want to impose no no i
i i i it's a rabbit hole of just
thinking about the
the uh the challenge of eyewitness
testimony on the basis
of uh all these various things because
of
the fact that you can you can overtly
plant false memories in people yeah
uh and and anyway but it's it truly is a
rabbit hole i wasn't even thinking of it
that way but as i'm saying it out loud
i'm realizing it is a full
about face so i'm going to be quiet and
truly look
because i had to raise my hand i felt
invest i felt like there were stakes now
i'm gonna play teacher's pet and um
i felt like there's this new or not not
a new necessarily because
obviously the games that we saw have
been in development longer i would think
longer than covet right yeah
triple a you might triple a i would say
probably they all started before covid
still if we're seeing them
now which we didn't see many triple a
right we saw
two maybe i i was saying this when i was
watching it that
like what does it even mean anymore
budget and scope
right like in the lines you could say
that some of those games
like returnal if it was published is
triple a but it's not
because it's how they're not a triple a
studio so it's like i don't even [ __ ]
know anymore
but my my point for that was that there
was this big
trend that i saw um yesterday you said
pixar style and there was a lot of
high fidelity stylized
art not it was photo real like everybody
was going photo reel right you had death
stranding and you had
um even from uncharted 4 on it was like
holy [ __ ] man that looks like a real
person
and then we see this trend based on what
we saw yesterday
of a lot of like more stylized
cartoonish pixary
it it might as well have been that the
latest pixar movie was coming out
i didn't know if that was a result of
we talked about the ps5 being able to
have kind of level the playing field for
for studios having access to
almost the same tools by which to create
incredible looking graphics
um not necessarily photo real but you
you could
studio a that's like a naughty dog or
whatever or studio b that's more of a
triple
i or even a smaller indie now has the
same kind of
they're all dealing with the same engine
it's it's the pine derby
kind of deal everyone's playing with the
same tools
is that why or is there something about
kovid that said we need to scale the way
we need to change our animation style
there's a show that i'm on right now
that hasn't chosen we've already started
recording and they haven't chosen their
animation studio yet
so i was like that seems like that would
be the first thing that that you would
do
but i just didn't know if covid kind of
drove that trend or if that trend was
already in place
i think it's actually the other viral
sensation of fortnite
if you look at the dates i would guess
because you have
basically when you're pitching games um
which is something unfortunate i've had
do many times in my career
you're always pointing you're always
trying to make the business case like
give us some money
it's this plus this yeah through the
lens of this
and like if you look at like the
breakout kind of hits of the last
five years there's actually not many
photo real games in there like in terms
of like the things that have like
dominated the conversation
or kind of creatively made a big
impression in that sense like
obviously lots of amazing photo real
games have come out but if you think
about like
what have we got like uh fortnite is the
new is that obviously the current and
new hotness but fortnite's been around
now for a surprisingly long amount of
time they have managed to achieve
longevity i remember
i remember going into rooms on john wick
when we were working on john wick and
and uh a film execs asking me like so is
this like fortnight and it's like no
i'll be honest with you it's nothing
like fortnite you know
and having that conversation that was
that was the game that people who don't
play
games had heard you know what it is what
they do is so
impressive like the announcement of the
alien stuff yesterday the travis scott
thing
like fortnite does a lot of very
impressive stuff as a platform it's
amazing
but i'm trying to tell you to say that
what's up
it's um you know it's so funny more
likely that's the impact
because even before that you had um like
i'm trying to think of like i guess
pubg was kind of um
kind of photo real but then like
definitely very indie kind of not like
cutting edge graphics right
i feel like the case for we need to do
photo reel
has faded and possibly the case for we
need to stand out
has improved and i think i wouldn't
pitch a a photo real game right now
because i think the market's showing us
that that
isn't the road to run towards like
that's not interesting
because of perception or because of is
there any
like cost like it's so expensive to do
that or is that is that because
i think we've i think the industry i
don't know if you guys can hear there's
like a really loud drilling sound
apologies if it's coming up in the show
so
but i don't i don't think i think it's i
think it's fashion i think
honestly like execs in the games
industry
are are exactly as as um
what's the word observant of trends
that's a good way of putting it
um as as players probably expect in the
like if they
see thing over here making lots of money
then as you say it's kind of the pitch
is
we're going to do that but we're going
to flip it in this way so they're going
to exactly
frustrate you though because how could
you be those trends you're observing
something in the past
yeah no it's it's not yeah you're always
looking backwards and that's flawed
i i get it though like if i was spending
millions of my own money
on projects i would probably be careful
and i'd probably base that on what i
thought would make money and and i'd
have to look at what was doing well
the other thing i think is interesting
is i think i think there is a technical
reason coming up that's interesting and
i think maybe this is getting the jump
and the technical reason is
photo reel is about to get cheap and
that's a really
interesting aspect i think of this
conversation we're not there yet
by any means but if you look at things
like this tom cruise deep fakes would
disagree those are pretty
my god they're but that's that's
honestly the the ai side of it is a part
of it like if you look at photogrammetry
if you look at ai
and the production of kind of photo real
content uh
via computing power essentially which is
getting
which obviously is always getting
cheaper if you look at specifically
photogrammetry is the one that jumps out
at me
if you look at things like epics um
humanoid character thing they they
dropped a couple of weeks ago that's
beautiful
um carmen boyd's called there'll be a
million comments pointing to you can
hear the drill now
you can hear the drill now that's that's
it's horrible it's messing my brain
basically photo we may be approaching a
time where photo reel
is actually cheaper than stylization and
at that point if you're
a company that where your differentiator
is you have budgets i.e
aaa how do you show off your budget how
do you use your budget
in a way indie con you don't do photo
real
the joke with games has always been that
the things that are really i think we've
said this on the show before
the things that are really easy to do
cheap to do with film
are most expensive in games and vice
versa i can make a city being destroyed
by a spaceship
much more easily than i can make two
people in a room talking to each other
and having an emotional kind of scene
together
that might be about to flip the techno a
lot of technology lines are kind of
converging which imply to me that like
photo reel might be an aesthetic that's
realistically approachable
for an indie at which point if i've got
30 million
i have a follow-up i go to stylization
that's what differentiates me
we might be at a point where in the same
way as disney animation
is a really expensive way to make a
story for kids right
but they have the money and resources to
do that so the differentiation is
actually to go stylized
not photo real which would just be a a
children's film which is much cheaper to
produce that might be about to flip but
that's years away that's not we're not
there yet
is um is there a
a version of this looking from a dev
site is there an attraction
several years ago joe madeira came in
and created
the um the aesthetic for darksiders like
he
he was the one who i love joe madd so do
i
um so i've always pronounced that matter
i've always pronounced his last name
matter raera
to his face i don't think i've ever said
it to his face
i think that's why he just goes joe mad
is there a world where
instead of getting and this is not
disparaging against but instead of
getting norman reedus instead of getting
um keanu reeves
instead of getting greg miller instead
of getting again you get
you get scott snyder you get joe madd
you get like
whoever the big you get guillermo del
toro
you get these people that that becomes
your big celebrity
star draw that you get instead of the
actor because it's no longer about the
photo realness of them
it is about the design
the the unique aesthetic the um
i worked on a game called absolver by
the studio slo clap that also had a
the kung fu game in the uh
run down yesterday i didn't work on it
for the record uh i love them though
they're fantastic
uh and um they um oh dear
right earthquake oh god
that was very strange a lot of things
had to be never been very expensive to
achieve
yeah the motion blur i was going to say
how did you enjoy the motion blur
the uh again another another spotify
moment of curiosity
uh the webcam fell yep there you go
and now it's all akimbo but uh the uh
because it's resting on my piano and so
like it's pushing down
the g natural which like tickles anyway
um
the uh the
slow clap team i remember when they were
in the early days
on absolver they went to like
milan or somewhere or they were planning
i'm the details are fuzzy because it's
years ago but they basically were hiring
a fashion designer
to help design their character avatars
and that was going to be one of their
big
you know marketing conceptions of the
game is that we went to one of these you
know when you look at these
really ultra sort of almost borderline
avant-garde runway shows
where their their their outfits are are
just these
absolutely over-the-top and and crazy
detailed and and really amazing some
some of these
some of these outfits are are just so
wild and imaginative and they were like
that's the kind of mind we want to help
do our character creation
that they're not thinking in terms of
game design or animation hookups or
or you know rigging and all that kind of
stuff that they just think in terms of
fabric
and light and i thought that was a
really cool way and i could see how
that might be a thing you know that that
we've got so and so
designer austin i feel like you are kind
of
that like to troy's question i am
clearly a man of discerning fashion
a fashionable joke joy's question is
about troy just died inside i think
it's about odds obviously but i think
that when you have austin wintry as your
composer that is a distinct choice that
you are making
um there was a game at the conference
yesterday the the follow-up to hyper
light drifter uh i don't know what it's
called but i was like this is an
austin wintery ass game uh because
there's a style of video game that you
are frequently attached to
and a a type of for the record
a good friend and fabulous composer
scoring that game rich vreeland
aka disaster piece who has also done a
hybrid light drifter before with those
which is also a great game
tremendous score why do i know disaster
peace he did fez
that's what i don't know he also did the
movie it follows uh
which was his kind of big foray into
film yeah he's a dope school
interesting he's everything he's done
but hyper lighting he's not home on
miami too
no nothing no yeah exactly it's it's
it's an outlier in the data just right i
think i think
i think you're right about austin like i
think ultimately what you're talking
about is already happening we just don't
have an audience who's literate
and not fruitful their own because those
people haven't been put in front of
cameras and
it's also been pushed that way that's
what kojima has been trying to do
is is well actually i know ea did it
back when it started they
they tried to pitch their dev teams as
boy bands they tried to
have photo shoots with their entire team
where they all looked they were
electrical
couches that's right that was how they
were they tried to make them seem like
they were bands where you would know all
of their names and you would know
everyone who worked on anything i mean
it certainly happened with doom
if the creators of doom everyone knows
their names are almost people not the
mainstream obviously but that is that is
a thing that they tried to push and it
didn't work when the teams became too
big i think
uh but kojima has certainly tried to do
that in that direction of like having
the opening credits of
of you know showing his name four times
but also a lot of other people's tapes
in that process and i think it's it is
ultimately dev teams being too big for
that to really take off but it's not
yeah it's not that those designer
choices don't exist because i would
i would say austin winter is a designer
choice
hmm it's funny because i it's it's
interesting how
i mean on the one hand that's probably
not a bad thing like i would i would
anytime let you know the any
conversations in the hollywood world
become about
you know how do you avoid or i should
say a common recurring thread is how do
i avoid becoming typecast because this
is sort of an offshoot of what you're
saying
you know oh well you're you're the
person who always works on such and such
or you always write
music that sounds like such and such and
the conventional wisdom would be
it's a very luxurious problem to be
typecast because
getting cast is problem number one and
if you can actually get over that
sufficient to now be repeatedly called
to do the same thing that means the
words out on you that you're really good
at that
i don't think all your music sounds the
same though my suggestion is more that
you are uh often paired with games
that have a not even a consistent style
but very distinct style like i would
think that if i heard that you were
attached to a game i would be like okay
i'm probably gonna enjoy this game
which for a composer is a pretty like
huge link but i still think that if i
hadn't heard austin wintry compose this
okay
i know what austin's kind of taste is
and i'm probably gonna like the game
that he worked on
what you're describing as well is like
other theory is originally
one of the original meanings of outer
theory we now think about her theory is
like
person who's in charge my video has gone
completely out of scene it has
again motion blur yeah there we go like
ota theory doesn't necessarily mean
person who is most important it can mean
person who you identify with things you
like so a good example of this for me
is i have a weird like
thing where i if ryan gosling's in a
film
i will enjoy that film i might not love
ryan gosling in that film but
something about the way he and his agent
select movies
is an indicator that i will like that
movie like it's a joke
it's a joke now that i will actively go
and find ryan gosling films
because i know he'll pick movies i would
like to see
and yeah that's what you're saying for a
different episode
yeah it's more of a curation type thing
in the case of austin i'm
definitely that's what you're saying is
the kind of projects you would like
yeah although it's worth saying that
there are plenty of projects
that composers in particular
are susceptible to this phenomenon but i
think everybody
is as well where you know you
you attend those initial meetings and
it's here's the thing we're gonna make
and everyone's real excited and then
flash to two years later and it's kind
of
drifted off course and by the time it
ships it's like well this is
really not the same thing that everybody
was sort of assuming it would be
and so it's a it's a it's i think a kind
of undue
leap of faith to say oh well you know he
he sure can pick
i basically see it from the other angle
that i've been very lucky that the
the games that i've worked on have a
better than
50 average of turning out pretty damn
good
but that's not thanks to me or even my
discerning taste in fact
i don't the game is rarely ever the the
thing that
makes me say yes it's always who i'm
working with you know
so much rather i think that's why the
good rate is it's the people you choose
to work
you pick a good team good stuff yeah 100
you're picking a good team it's usually
going to result in a good product or at
least you have that taste but regardless
austin like
you're right it isn't necessarily
logical to perceive it that way
uh but i do feel like we had a lot of
people mention in the comments that they
played the pathless because of you
and having a composer encourage people
to play a game is
is pretty cool it's funny because that's
just so not novel to me because my whole
childhood was like oh a new movie's out
that jerry goldsmith scored i'm going to
go see that movie and then and then
being hard
up you that's why you ended up well i
think but i think that's another thing
that helps there
is it's about visibility as well though
right one of the reasons that the
audience
knows austin and looks for his name on
the credits is
well a because of obviously things like
this doing doing show together but
before that because your name's on the
album and i think that goes a long way i
think
your name is out front in a way on a
tertiary product like someone likes a
game
they put the they put it on spotify
while they're at work or whatever
and they see your name come up and i
think that's that's the big one it's
just making
is is it's really i don't other than
like even an art book
an art book is going to have the work of
lots of different people in it the art
director is probably going to take a
step back
it's kind of one of those weird things
of like yeah if the name's not out there
then p we we can't expect people to
gravitate towards it which is why
the directors you know push to get their
names above the credits which is why
actors get their names on the posters
and have massive arguments about
how their name is gonna be placed on the
poster and all that jazz like
yeah what am i talking about one of my
to that end
uh one of my favorite examples of the
kind of
unintentional backfiring of the
confirmation bias type
thing that emerges from what you're
talking about is
obviously after journey came out i was
the beneficiary of a lot of
goodwill from people at large
and um so maybe a year or two
after that so relatively shortly after
journey came out i get a call from
a guy who i uh i kind of knew him
because composers
you know the community's small enough
that even if you haven't met someone
you've probably heard their name if
if they're around and actively engaging
with people even if they haven't done
anything
that you might have heard of that you
know usually see people's names around
especially with facebook you know
there's facebook groups that are
basically all composers and things
so a composer who i was not familiar
with musically but i'd seen his name
calls me up uh and he says
i'm working on a game and
i feel like it's turning out really well
and
we have a pretty narrow budget and
normally the stuff i've worked on i've
had basically no budget so i always
mixed stuff myself
but i feel like i'm going to be able to
squeeze a little bit of budget out of
this to hire a mixer and i just thought
i'd call to ask your advice
on if you think that's a worthwhile use
of resources
in your experience because you're you
know this is most of my friends
only know about movies as a as a fellow
game person
you know what's your take on on hiring a
score mixer
and you know do you have someone you
would recommend i said oh well i said i
think it's extremely worthwhile if you
can squeeze the money for it
and i got a guy who works really great
named steve kempster and i would be
thrilled to put you two in touch
and i'll you know i'll tell him you know
this would be this would be worth your
time so
the composer was gareth coker and the
game was orion the blind forest
and so he gave me a special thanks like
at the bottom of the box
like he got moon studios to include me
in the block of special thanks
and to your point as soon as that game
came out
i started getting tweets of people going
i saw you in the credits i didn't know
you scored
ori that's so cool and i'm like do you
know how
hard you had to look at like gareth's
name
prominently music by and then like an
hour later
in this wall of text of special thanks
and that's like
every all you know what's happening yeah
i was gonna say half of them are like
the siblings and the parents of the
developers and stuff you know it's like
and and so i was like man it's so funny
how once you've
once you kind of got a thing in your
head i had the same thing happen
uh to a far lesser degree but i had a
similar thing happen
a number of times recently with hades
because again i contributed
at least there actually did help in a
more substantive way than answering a
phone call and then
writing an email uh but uh but i uh
uh i've gotten a lot of folks oh my god
i had no idea you scored hades and i'm
like in no way did i score hades
i'm i'm i'm i'm there's a certain amount
of
sweetness in your presumption and it's
like oh i knew it was good and now i get
why and i'm like that's very nice but
woefully wrong um and also i would never
have written that score
i would have written something different
if you loved it all
all hails to darren corb so anyway it's
just one of those funny things that i've
never experienced that i've never
experienced
a name jumping out where you recognize
it
but they don't even notice like the
context in which they recognize it
because
they're like composer yeah exactly yeah
i think
it's sort of similar note and i have no
idea what i'm even gonna do about this
but
uh anything that santa monica studios
makes that people don't like
i will get blamed for and i'm already so
aware of that if there is
anything in i fully plan on blaming it
it's gonna happen
it's gonna be like because i wanna talk
to you about games that were
from ten years ago oh my fault actually
yeah a lot of it's my fault but i'm
i'm already so acutely aware of the fact
that that's going to happen even for
things that i had absolutely nothing to
do with and i'm like
i guess i'll just take it but then if i
did do anything that was good they would
probably credit someone else
i'm like i'm just so aware of the
reality of that me pending on me
maybe probably mike bethel will get
credit for it yeah usually i get credit
for it
someone called you our resident
socialist the other day and i was like
he's comma business
just as much
to that to that end when you mentioned
something about troy
a second ago when talking about fortnite
you said troy made me say that
it made me because someone sent me their
podcast over email the other day and it
was a link to the apple podcast
upload of their podcast and i realized
because i mostly use spotify for that
sort of thing i
i don't ever look at apple podcast and i
remember i was
skimming through the reviews and i had
this sudden thought of i've never
actually seen
our show especially because i always
hear you say you know the audio version
has a different title
so i jumped over and i looked looked us
up and i was perusing through the
reviews
and side by side oh it's hilarious
most of them are very sweet like
overwhelmingly people
everyone give us a nice review if you'd
like that'd be cool yeah it gives us a
nice review on uh
my favorite side by side side-by-side
reviews
were i [ __ ] love troy baker i would
i would listen to anything involving
troy baker next one over
what the [ __ ] is it with austin mike and
alana that they have to suck troy's dick
every week it
it was it was so like i mean i thought
we had to do that i thought that was one
of the stipulations not contractually
it's more of an unwritten how would we
get him to stay around we knew he'd have
quite if he didn't do it so
actually i would have quit if i didn't
do it so it uh
no it was it was last week where it was
like this is infuriating i'm getting
very annoyed that you aren't talking
about video games and then
every other comment is oh i really like
the episode so you don't talk about
video games and this is a thing that
like i've just learned over the
course of my career is that it's very
difficult to actually take feedback from
people on the internet because
it's in every direction at all times and
people think completely opposite things
you kind of have to
source it from peers because and that's
not to like discredit audiences like i
always want the feedback especially had
some
really useful stuff that i passed on to
the uh audio editor that i've been using
uh
i was like can we try compressing the
show people in cars say that it's too
loud or too quiet and so he did that and
it's like
it's like people without knowing that
the compression was added have been like
oh the show sounds even better and it's
like cool great feedback very helpful um
but generally speaking it's like
we just can't like i just can't do
anything to please
90 000 people who all feel very
differently about troy baker and
whether we suck him off too much too
much by the way is the quality yeah
it's not not that we do it or don't do
it at all it's just the limit to which
you do it
it's too much it's a binary one yeah
yeah whereas this is a more of a
gassing up austin episode oh yeah
clearly
um a little payback we'll get a turn we
all get a turn
eventually yeah i mean that's the funny
thing that's that's uh that's the like
like to i have to kind of skirt around
some
um ndas but i was i was recently on a
uh a jury
for awards considerations um
and i was like i don't when when
invariably uh the last of us comes up i
was like i don't think
i have a i certainly don't technically
have a conflict of interest
but i'm i'm i'm i'm as close as you can
get
i feel like at this point on on this one
that i have a real hard time speaking
truly objectively uh just given the
amount of
buy-in at this point that i've built in
just with
certain individuals and it doesn't
actually stop with our gentleman here
there are plenty of folks that i wish
very well and therefore it clouds my
thinking but i had a similar thing
recently where somebody
uh like on something like that
criticized
a voice performance um of an actor that
i'm friends with not troy
but whom i also dearly love and i
couldn't believe how like how much it
hurt me i was like
like i was like how dare you because i i
thought that performance was fantastic
but it also like hit me in a way to like
have someone be like [ __ ] trash
performance i was like oh my god
because like especially when you're
hearing it right like if you
ever like i didn't even actually like as
someone who's been nominated for lots of
awesome one
as many of them as i'd like but i've
been nominated the knowledge that people
have been that mean about stuff we've
done in those rooms because
everyone's always a nightmare in those
rooms i've actually i've had i've had to
do the troy opt out a couple of times
where i've been on panels of
and i've had to have to quietly like
duck out and be like
i like troy so i can't i can't judge him
on this
um i've always found to be
this to be pretty true um
there's a difference between having
critical discourse you know and saying
well let's discuss this thing
from either an academic or whatever
and just kind of water cooler [ __ ] talk
and people will only
[ __ ] talk if they feel that they have an
open audience
and by and large that means that the
person who is
currently the receptor of the [ __ ] talk
is
also a purveyor or if they feel they can
get away with it
exactly i feel like they have power in
that room but it's not always about the
other person being an [ __ ] it's
sometimes the
it's often that the the [ __ ] thinks
that no one can stop them being an
[ __ ] we see that in
all areas of life right i mean i i love
when people like
unhinged uh criticized games i have a
friend who's also a writer jess jojo who
has opinions that i so staunchly
disagree with and and will say like
very opinionated stuff with no filter
and i love that she hasn't had it beaten
into her that she should have a filter
we've been playing uh red dead online
for fun um
and like she will be playing with us and
she'll just be like this video game's
[ __ ] trash and i'm like
jess would disagree with you but please
continue like the fire which was she
expresses video game opinions like to
her friends and openly and a lot of
stuff she writes as well is like really
refreshing
because it's so easy to be scared of
people on the internet where video games
are concerned because the the discourse
could just be so vitrulic
and i'm like don't change just jojo
mashable just jojo i think she's just at
jess jojo on all of social media but
a lot of very strong opinions i uh i
think especially in a
in a um super strong
opinions that are not just
knee-jerk sort of like man but actually
coming from some place that's
informed in some form or another i that
i
again i i can't really get into it but i
was on the same
um recent awards jury thing
i i i held back a little but i
definitely had one of those moments
where i was like look i think this
this game i've got some major
major problems with this game and i i
was pretty
open and not trashing it but like i
think that this thing fundamentally
fails in its conceit and i just
cannot fathom how anybody could see it
otherwise and then it and then it was so
joyous
to me is that then like three or four
other people in the jury were
like here's exactly why you're wrong and
with equal
equal enthusiasm defending the game and
it you know
i didn't they didn't change my opinion
in that case but it has been changed
before
but they also did give me something to
think about in a way that
i was grateful for it so i i love that i
the idea that you should be filtered or
polite
um i don't ascribe to at all uh
especially if you've thought a lot about
it and you're like all worked up because
you're just
loaded with with you know you're loaded
for bear
is is rad seeing people get passionate
about things is cool it's it sucks when
it's
directed at yeah for sure does a game
that i played recently called before i
forget
uh believe it's on playstation
definitely on pc what are we talking
about
i so i so want to talk about this game
you have no idea
oh really uh well yeah it uh
some of the reviews that i was reading
uh were
quite negative uh there are a lot of a
lot of
fair criticisms of the game but i feel
like i took so much more away from it
than other people because
it does uh have themes that deal with
dementia
and i have had family members
who have dementia so it's something that
i felt like i was like oh wow the way
they did that
that particular thing was really
powerful or like you know this moment
was really strong that i feel like other
people didn't resonate with at all
and that was obviously extremely
subjective um and surely i'm sure they
could have
you know framed that game a little bit
more educationally where
that theme is concerned but it was an
interesting thing to read reviews and be
like oh this
this actually like upset me playing this
a little bit where some other people
were like
hated it trash interesting that's just
that just like upset meaning affected
you
or upset meaning uh no just yeah
affected me not
i wasn't like the video game was bad and
they cried it was uh it was uh oh wow
this made me think about
spoke to you you know just the context
of this and how i would feel if i was
going through this
we we probably don't have time today to
to do a proper
breakdown of that because that that game
specifically of all the games that i've
played in the last year that one has
given me the most
sort of food for thought on the subject
of
how to what's your final assessment of a
game
when the game itself feels
a little clunky but
what they are exploring is so potent
and they do it just well enough that it
sticks with you
because you know they're not just saying
oh here's our here's our sci-fi story
and our hero's journey and our whatever
like
that's a game explicitly made to gamify
from a first-person perspective the
experience of like alzheimer's basically
or dementia
and it it does it in a way that you know
it
puts you in that space and it's
frustrating and it's scary
and it's all those things and it really
puts you there
but it's it's kind of like it's sort of
like
for me it's sort of this year's that
dragon cancer where
it it's it it felt like probably really
young
developers you know who are taking it's
their most ambitious
project that they still have like 45
minutes everyone could just go play it
totally yeah i was about to ask what did
you play it on i played it on tv
yeah yeah i'll check it out it's
legitimately a 45 minute game it's you
know it's and it's
i totally agree austin it's a really
interesting one to criticize and i'm
glad that i
didn't have to review it because uh
there are things that feel like there
are flaws with the game
but you're right that the potency of the
theme is so strong
um and i think expects pretty well um
yeah i won't spoil it but there's a
particular thing that that happens if
you're like
you forget where something is and i was
like oh this
is just very very well done uh and
and ties into the gameplay rather than
just being a bunch of things i'm reading
um a very difficult game to review i
would think it would
be vastly different depending on your
experience uh what's the garden radio
play
do you see this um they're they're doing
a special on steam right now before i
forget buy before i forget plus the
garden radio play
um
maybe the game is that effective that
we've forgotten it uh
and it's like it's really it's really
it's really rewritten
i love mike i love mike's like my my
temperature check on how gallows my
humor can get
yeah it probably is alzheimer's and not
dementia that would probably be
well they were specifically partnered
with alzheimer's research uk
yeah that's the thing and that that game
basically losing
cognitive faculty is essentially my
worst nightmare
because i there's very little to me
other than that i'm not like this
great athlete or or any like i'm not
even even in the realm of music i don't
consider myself
much of a performer you know i like
conducting concerts and
a little piano here and there but
there's a thousand people better at both
of those to be
blunt especially piano um i really to me
thinking which writing music is
essentially a function of thinking and
and dreaming that's all that i that i am
i
i would my lifestyle would would be only
fractionally altered if i was reduced to
a
futurama floating head in a vat and i
so to me a game that explores what it's
like for your brain
to start breaking down its basic
abilities to retain
information into is is is literally a
a game of my worst nightmare for myself
i think there's also something
interesting to explore there as far as
um there's also a lot of significant
studies have been done about how people
who do have alzheimer's um
can instantly sing again play the piano
again instantly
because there's something about their
brain that processes
music from a completely different
standpoint also people who
um severe autism who uh maybe even
non-verbal
are able to communicate that way so it's
music to me is fascinating and i i go
back to what um
uh alice roberts said as far as like
there's a lot of studies to support the
fact that we were singing before we were
talking that talking is actually a much
more reductive form of
communication i just think that's well
in our speech
the speech center of the brain is also a
very specific part of the brain whereas
music is kind of crowdsourced over
huge parts of the brain because you are
you are drawing on a lot of
parallel skills that's a big part of why
for um
childhood development like k-5 music
education
is not about exposing kids to
the you know to music such that they
might grow up and become
more musical or people always make these
very reductive arguments of oh well you
know you have to count rhythms so maybe
they'll be better at math it's like no
no it makes you
think better it makes you retain
information more powerfully because
you're basically building pathways
early on your brain is creating all
these pathways in itself
and when it's at its most plastic and
it's most malleable the more pathways
you build the
just the higher your cognitive capacity
later in life will be and music is one
of those things that
creates pathways everywhere it it by
virtue of being able to do it there's a
the the oliver sacks book music ophelia
gets into a lot of these
uh kinds of things and he cites a lot of
studies and my favorite one was
that there was a patient um a patient
who was suffering recurring
severe seizures to the point that
the only like that like literally they
were essentially in a continuous
state of seizure indefinitely like they
were
they they had a non-viable life
effectively at this point and they
weren't a vegetable they just couldn't
get out of this state
and so um the yeah
it's like a waking nightmare you know
and so they they um the extreme
solution was essentially a lobotomy of
half their brain
um and they would still be able to
uh do certain things and and have you
know something
vaguely resembling a normal life after
and the thing that was so fascinating
was that the speech
center was in the half of the brain that
was lost so the person lost the ability
to speak for the rest of their life
but they could still sing as a way to to
communicate
what and the what the thing that i found
so amazing about that and
the question that i've always wanted to
see if any if any neuro
scientist has studied um on the back of
that revelation is
it's not such a hard line between
singing and speaking a lot of time you
know like like listen to
a lot of hip-hop for example that
they're not speaking by any
measure of i would say they're also not
typically
opera singers where it's oh it's there's
there's very little that you could call
speaking baked in it
in term well i'm not going to go down to
the technical distinction i just
made a mess of but uh point being it's
there's a it's kind of a gradation right
there's a there's a spectrum from
singing to speaking and
the idea of the brain surely has some
point
or a blurry little narrow band
in which you've kind of made the leap
where as you as you got more
speaky as you sang at some point it
would just you'd hit a
floor you couldn't go past i wonder yeah
what the limit is it would probably be
on an individual basis
of what's too singy for you les
miserables
that's probably no but i mean like in
the case of that we are just going to
talk at one note and then it will sound
like we're singing
well so that that comes from opportunity
that's called wrestling
really come on i know i love playing
i love like like embarrassing i've seen
it too many times
i've seen any song isn't pam the reason
you've seen it too many times though
my wife has seen that my wife has seen
that a production a stage production of
that
at least 20 times i think i'm up to
three i think
we've done four in london yeah
it's look it is good uh i was gonna add
the note uh this is
a very uncultured note in comparison of
uh
i've been criticized before because
people from australia and the uk
uh often if we end a phone call we sing
it's bye-bye all right see you later oh
bye
and you you do that here so that's yeah
okay uk does the same
thing supposedly doesn't do that you
just say all right bye but we go
goodbye i don't know why it happens we
sing when we say goodbye
it's very strange because we're
generally right now texas does it
everybody does it
there is a lyrical we still sing
we speak at a certain pace we typically
speak at a certain key like if you were
to listen to the notes
it's not a tonal it's it's there's
there's very much of
music to the way that we speak yeah is
that conscious thing for you as a
professional speaker do you consciously
think about the
about like the sing-song nature of
speech is that something you turn off or
on is that
is that tool that you're conscious of or
is that just does that flow from
character
for you i would say in the same way that
austin can
go back here and do this and know what
notes he's going to hit i would do the
same thing with speaking if i'm wanting
to make a specific point i'm going to
speak at a specific pace
my pitch is going to go up or go down
but it's not going to be
make sure you do this in the same way
that
as a as using your voice as as an acting
tool
if someone says hey i need this to feel
more menacing
that's typically the other side of the
equal sign of that is going to be like
maybe we should go low add some gravel
to it that's going to be more
there's certain qualities that we
associate certain musicalities to that
vocal quality that we associate with
certain
characteristics or intention but it's
it's no longer
i think the second that you the second
that i
um am consciously trying that then it
feels put on
yeah i've definitely worked with actors
who've done who've had that kind of
artificiality to the process that
they've
yeah that i've given them some direction
like the flows from character or
or from the story and they'll come back
with so higher pitch
it's like that's always struck me as
something that was a bit a bit too
mechanical like it's something that you
can arrive at yourself and kind of
it's an interesting thing yeah it's
funny how that director just go let's
try that and see what happens okay
that's not that's not giving it to me
let's try something different
of course yeah yeah as a flip on that
like the same scenario but with the
opposite solution i have been conducting
orchestras
so many times where i'll hear you know
some some feature of what they played
and i'll say okay let's do it again
and let me just try to add some context
that might be helpful
it's a scene where this this couple
who've been you know hating each other
for the whole time they finally
they're finally finding this moment of
reconciliation and so we're kind of
cracking through the
exterior and and and getting into the
meat of their real intent and their real
how they actually feel about it how they
actually care
the concert masters say so louder
energy and invariably i'm like yeah
louder
[Laughter]
i've found a lot of times in sessions
and i do i must
unfortunately wrap up um but i have
found in sessions a lot of times
the simple act of externalizing the
notion
for the sake of the room frames it in
context
to where i could literally do the exact
same taking people like that's it
they just needed to hear themselves say
it like they they literally could have
been
in the moment where they go i never
thought about this but he's actually
he's not angry he's afraid and if you
listen back to it
they contextualize it themselves so
i don't i think that as funny as it is
to
to like go into the the pathos of the
moment and and
and try to uh you know as you say crack
that and and evoke this beautiful
imagery is like
so you want us to play it faster then
that idea of like direction that happens
at the moment of saying it and kind of
realizing what you mean through the act
of communicating it
is a thing that we have a term for
internally that i cannot say on the
podcast i've just realized
i'll tell it to you after you stop
recording i can't i just realized i've
done an awful thing there i apologize
and on that note yeah we should end the
show so we can find out what this term
is yeah
but actually because we have to so i
mean it's so evil goodbye
goodbye